[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con buena parte
de américa del sur dio inicio al nuevo
ciclo escolar y vuelve el debate sobre
mantener la virtualidad de las clases o
regresar a la presencialidad un momento
muy importante para el reto que implica
la pandemia del cob y 19 en la región es
un reto para las escuelas para los
padres de familia los maestros y por
supuesto para los sistemas educativos
para conversar sobre este tema está con
nosotros aquí en france24 claudia uribe
ella es directora de la oficina de
educación para américa latina y el
caribe de la unesco bienvenida france24
señora uribe gracias por estar con
nosotros y llevamos pocas semanas de
haber iniciado las clases este nuevo
ciclo académico cuál es el balance que
ustedes hacen hasta el momento
y muchas gracias y buenos días bueno la
región avanza lenta gradualmente hacia
la reapertura de las escuelas para las
clases presenciales en este momento la
mayor parte de los países de américa
latina lo están haciendo como le digo de
una manera muy cuidadosa muy segura y
muy gradual sólo 10 países en la región
mantienen las escuelas cerradas en este
momento señora uribe dada la brecha
tecnológica que hay en américa latina'
que vimos a lo largo de este año
excluyó a millones de estudiantes es
necesario regresar entonces a la
presencialidad lo más rápido posible
como lo bien ven ustedes mire nosotros
le damos un gran sentido de urgencia el
retorno porque como usted dice en
nuestra región aproximadamente el 46 por
ciento de los niños hasta los 12 años
viven en hogares en donde no hay
conectividad por
tanto son niños y niñas que han estado
parcialmente excluidos de la posibilidad
de continuar sus aprendizajes por otro
lado se sabe que las escuelas son
lugares que cumplen además de funciones
de aprendizaje cumplen muchas funciones
sociales es un espacio de contención
socio-emocional es es una instancia de
socialización muy importante y es un
lugar en donde se prestan variados
servicios sociales
entonces el retorno es de la mayor
urgencia son espacios muy importantes
para el desarrollo de los jóvenes señora
uribe llevamos ya prácticamente un año
de pandemia de kobe 19 en la región de
américa latina' bueno en el mundo en
realidad en cuanto al acceso a la
educación el acceso a la conectividad
qué lecciones les deja a ustedes este
año de pandemia
bueno mire por una parte nos muestra
aspectos muy positivos en torno a la
resiliencia de los sistemas educativos y
al compromiso de miles de docentes que
han trabajado arduamente por mantener la
continuidad educativa por otro lado
también nos damos cuenta de que sin duda
la educación presencial no es
sustituible por muchos esfuerzos y mucho
trabajo que hagamos a través de la
educación a distancia esto jamás va a
sustituir la interacción personal entre
los alumnos y sus docentes y con sus
compañeros así que vemos esa renovada
importancia de la educación por otro
lado hemos visto como los cierres han
aumentado unas brechas enormes que ya
tenían la región en materia de
aprendizajes en materia de acceso a la
educación en donde las poblaciones más
vulnerables
han estado siempre en desventaja y dónde
está donde estas desventajas se han
profundizado claramente el reto se ha
multiplicado en términos de educación
para la región de américa latina creen
ustedes que esto va a cambiar por
completo la forma de educarnos de
aprender de estudiar después de la
pandemia y lo que nos ha enseñado y que
usted nos ha explicado a lo largo de
esta entrevista
mire yo yo creo que sí yo creo que hay
muchos aspectos de lo que se ha
instalado durante este periodo que van a
continuar por un tiempo y quizás de
manera permanente de cierta manera hemos
visto la necesidad por ejemplo en
términos curriculares de poder de poder
reducirlos de poder priorizar los yo
creo que eso es algo que va a continuar
y que se va a mantener por otro lado
hemos visto pues el potencial de acción
a distancia
claudia uribe directora de la oficina de
educación para américa latina y el
caribe de la unesco muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros en conexión
con france24 ustedes pueden seguir en
sintonía de nuestra programación
[Música]